les attentats à la pudeur mais c'est moi
ça court ça c'est pour le dit matt t'as
pas honte
je pose notre café c'est comme ça merci
martin
écoute
j'avais en nature ici
[Musique]
pour éviter les longues routes
et au cou
avant cet accord
pour pouvoir rigoler je comprends pas là
où cette fois la balle et s'il vous
plaît sinon tu ris je ne sais pas
naturel alors c'est pas naturiste
alors il est où le truc naturiste celle
aucune idée pour le camp nudiste mais je
pense pas que ce soit dans le court non
il m'a dit au bois de boulogne tu verras
il ya plein de nanas à poil et où le
soir à ses limites
ils veulent pas qu'on se mette tenue et
dans le bois ah non non
avec l'interdît qu'avec moi as interdit
de se mettre tout nu
ces terres 10 mois et fils mais moi je
mange donc je peux mettre tout nu ici
avec vous ou encre à rien
non non ce n'était pas l'affairé serait
un tram n a pas bon
et vous ne
saurez machin travesti 1 la prison c'est
rien du tout moi je peux rester dans la
poitrine à l'air moi je ne va plus rien
à [ __ ] ah ouais donc il faut que je me
mettais mexès est différent non c'est
pas la même chose qu'un mec donc je me
mets un petit coup de rouge à lèvres
puis c'est bon non thermique c'est
différent de moi bon ben je vais aller
voir autant d'accords monde les renards
dames et messieurs dames savez quand
vous n'êtes pas vraiment eu sa peau ni
l'exhibition sexuelle ça deux à trois
poils comme ça mais je descends
dans les ports sata perrocheau non non
non les grandes pelouses à longchamp et
bien la loi de se mettre cul nu ah non
pas qu'une ou non
11 et la limite pour les femmes le mono
ça passe encore mais la porte loin une
femme à poil ou à ghazi à poil c'est
clair c'est
exhibition sexuelle là également alors
on a des collègues qui vont là-bas
wiimote et y aller ils sont tout nus non
des collectes grands patrons comme nous
adacore
vous sortez ci faisait pas un temps pour
s'amuser ça pour toi c'est pour les
vacances
mais non j'ai pas fait ça y est
[Musique]